the internet offers a wide range of
subscription services that ship you a
big box full of stuff every month course
there's Luke Craig great one
ships nerd culture collectibles to geeks
like me there's Birchbox which sends out
a bundle of beauty products to geeks
like me then there's bait crate which is
curated an array of supplies for the
avid masturbator I'm really good
so good at it this is 2017 and
absolutely everything is politicized or
something we can jerk off to now
President Trump has his own introducing
the big league box I know that's not
Trump's euphemism for Raquel Welch's
vagina it is a new subscription service
offered by the Trump pence reelection
campaign yes the reelection campaign
we're in an unending hell of constant
campaigning and never ends and for the
nice price of $69 per month what you'll
be sent quote a hand-picked bundle of
exclusive and vintage official Donald J
Trump merchandise feels appropriate from
a man who gets his wives through the
mail so comedians what is something
what's something you'd find in Donald
Trump's big league box sebastian bach a
chachi chachi yes boys very good Alison
Becker semen that's farm-to-table uh
Horatio fleshlight Minnie yes boy very
good about time last time